cette semaine en quête chasse à l'homme
d'un groupe d'internautes qui traquait
man iota depuis un an et demi et
essayait de le localiser
regardez attentivement la vidéo et on en
a conclu qu'elle était bien real et b on
avait un sérieux problème
c'est un des pires cas de maltraitance
envers des animaux que j'ai jamais vu
cette personne veut un public
il est fier de ce qu'il fait ils se
donnent en spectacle
tous les signes était tout indiqué qu'il
allait tuer quelqu'un je veux dire il
est vraiment suis quelqu'un et ça nous a
rendus malades acquis voire notre
prédiction soit réalisé
[Musique]
bienvenue enquête c'est un des meurtres
les plus horribles avoir été commis au
canada celui de ligne jaune perpétré au
printemps dernier à montréal dont est
accusé luca manute à cet homme au
comportement bizarre arrêtées à berlin
ce qui est troublant dans cette histoire
c'est que de nombreux think captée sur
internet laissait présager le pire
plusieurs internautes reprochent aux
autorités policières de ne pas avoir
pris assez au sérieux les signaux que
maillot tu as laissé sur le web
nous avons évité de vous montrer dans ce
reportage les singes insupportable des
meurtres de chatons et de line john
enquête sur une chasse à l'homme du
xxième siècle
18 juin 2012 au terme d'une chasse à
l'homme mondiale luca manioc ta débarque
à montréal
escortés comme une star mais les
menottes aux poings il est accusé du
meurtre de l'étudiant chinois line john
survenu deux semaines plus tôt sur son
visage on décèle l'ombre d'un sourire
luca magna obtient enfin ce qu'il a
toujours désiré la célébrité
i was il avait besoin d'attention il en
avait besoin comme vous et moi avons
besoin d'air pour respirer
luca fait partie de ces personnes qui
rêve de devenir une star mais il n'a pas
ce qu'il faut pour y arriver
le meurtre a été mise en scène filmée et
diffusée à la grandeur du monde sur
internet et aux conséquences ils
savaient exactement ce qu'ils faisaient
est un génie magnifique
yvan pendant un an et demi
un groupe d'internautes passionnés à
traquer luca manioc tas sans relâche sur
internet
oui on savait qu'il était une bombe à
retardement et qu'on devait agir
rapidement ils ont presque réussi à le
faire arrêter quelques semaines avant le
meurtre de line john un jour de plus un
indice de plus et on tenait
on voulait pas lâcher selon e line john
serait peut-être encore en vie
aujourd'hui si leur enquête et leur
crainte avait été prise plus au sérieux
heureuse et ça nous avons du mal à z de
voir notre prédiction se réalise et de
voir que malgré tous nos efforts ce
qu'on a tenté d'empêcher était arrivé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
revenons maintenant sur cette affaire
sordide démembrements cadavres à
montréal le meurtre de line john est un
des premiers meurtres commis pour être
vu sur internet un crime du 21e siècle
même si l'histoire est sordide nous
croyons qu'il faut la raconter pour en
tirer les leçons qui s'imposent
tout a commencé un an et demi avant la
mort de ligne jaune
le 21 décembre 2010 en banlieue de new
york
japan's est chez lui dans son bureau
lorsqu'il reçoit un courriel
on a reçu un courriel concernant une
vidéo
je me souviens pas précisément du texte
mais il faisait référence à la vidéo
regardez ça c'est très perturbant la
vidéo est quasi insupportable sans
aucune émotion apparente un jeune homme
place deux chatons dans un sac et les
asphyxies à l'aide d'un aspirateur
on a regardé attentivement la vidéo et
on en a conclu qu'elle était bien réel
les b qu'on avait un sérieux problème
[Musique]
japan's est la vedette d'une émission de
télé américaine qui met en scène un
groupe de motards venant à la rescousse
d'animaux maltraités
il en a vu d'autres mais cette fois ci
il a l'impression d'avoir découvert un
monstre quelqu'un qui va probablement
rester dit les ouïes besson s'est dit
qu'il fallait trouver cette personne
dans une banlieue de washington ryan
ball qui passent plusieurs heures par
jour à naviguer sur internet découvre la
même vidéo il est dégoûté ça a été
viscéral très choqué ça m'a tellement
bouleversée qu'immédiatement j'ai voulu
faire quelque chose on est retourné sur
le web
ai-je écrit une page facebook
ryan ball créé une page facebook dans
laquelle il demande aux gens de l'aider
à identifier et à faire arrêter le tueur
de chatons
120 une vidéo sur youtube pour demander
de l'aide pour aller à la pêche
si vous avez des informations joignez
vous au groupe facebook rester anonyme
donnez nous des indices mme
en quelques semaines le groupe compte
des milliers de membres
l'enquète démarre en trombe brian boyle
créer un sous groupe secret de 25
personnes qui vont l'aider à diriger
l'enquète il baptise ce sous-groupe les
individus utile
[Musique]
pendant ce temps à los angele wine
voulez que je fasse partie du groupe
useful to beat chose parce que j'avais
de bons contacts avec la police et le
fbi avec les organismes de protection
des animaux mais surtout avec les médias
si à barbie est une ex pin up de
renommée internationale avec shane sa
soeur jumelle
elle a fait les beaux jours du magazine
playboy dans les années 90 depuis les
deux soeurs sont devenus les brigitte
bardot américaine d activiste radical
qui ont des contacts dans toutes les
organisations de défense des animaux
à moins que je suis allé voir chaque
grand organisme de protection des
animaux
je leur ai dit vous devez regarder cette
vidéo parce que c'est un des pires cas
de maltraitance envers les animaux que
j'ai jamais vu malheureusement les
grands organismes plein de ressources
m'ont répondu que cette vidéo était
truquée et ancien
rescue inc est le seul organisme de
protection des animaux qui a
immédiatement accepté nous aider ils ont
tout de suite répondu on est au courant
on est sur le coup et on accepte de
coopérer avec vous et les barbies twins
vont presque en faire une obsession
c'était génial de voir qu'il y avait
autant d'activistes animalier et de jean
travers le monde bouleversé et outré par
le fait que quelqu'un puisse faire de
telles choses
deux internautes qui utilise le
pseudonyme de john green et bogut
mauvaises sont particulièrement choqués
ils ont exigé l'anonymat parce qu'ils
enquêtent sur d'autres crimes commis
contre les animaux et craignent pour
leur sécurité
on a analysé la vidéo image par image
il y en avait des milliers ont cherché
des éléments qui indiquerait où il était
on regardait les prises de courant
les poignées de porte l'aspirateur le
sac de compression la couverture le
format du lit est ce que c'est un format
européen un format nord américain
c'était des éléments importants les
éléments analysés indique que le crime
aurait été commis au canada ou en europe
mais on n'en sait pas plus puis une
série de photos vient s'ajouter à la
vidéo elle est mise en ligne par un
internaute anonyme
on a reçu les photos après la vidéo dans
la première photo où l'on voyait un
garçon qui tenait deux chats dans les
airs il y avait aussi une autre photo
montrant des deux chats morts dans un
vieux réfrigérateur
et puis il y avait sept photos
provocantes d'un jeune homme sur un lit
avec deux chats mais son visage était
brouillée
des membres du groupe facebook s'attaque
à l'analyse des données numériques des
photos il découvre que celle-ci montrant
les chatons vivant a été prise le 19
novembre 2010 celle-là des mêmes chaton
dans un réfrigérateur a été prise trois
jours plus tard on sait maintenant que
les chatons ont été tuées entre le 19 et
le 22 novembre 2010 mais on ne sait
toujours pas où il décide de donner un
second souffle à lenquête on a offert
lui récompense on a placardé des avis de
recherche toute personne qui nous
donnerait une information permettant de
le trouver de l'identifier de l'arrêter
et de le faire accuser seraient
récompensés
de los angele cia barbie fait jouer ses
contacts dans les médias j'ai demandé à
mon ami d'écrire un article sur rescue
inc dans lequel il parlerait de la
récompense de 5000 $ ça nous a permis de
rediriger tous les indices et les infos
vers le groupe youth for individual pour
nous permettre éventuellement de le
retracer cet article sur le tueur de
chatons paraît le 28 décembre 2010 sur
un site internet fréquentés par des
millions de lecteurs
depuis le début luca magna semble suivre
la progression de l'enquète sur le site
facebook
il n'a toujours pas été identifié par
les internautes mais il est inquiet
nous avons découvert qu'au début de
janvier 2011 lukla manioc tas s'est
rendu à new york où il a consulté
l'avocat roméo salta il avait peur de se
faire arrêter pour cruauté envers les
animaux
il craignait aussi que certains
activistes animaliers ou d'autres s'en
prennent à lui alors il m'a contacté
pour savoir quelle était la situation
s'il y avait ou pas des mandats d'arrêt
contre lui j'ai vérifié il n'y en avait
pas après cette rencontre luca manyoza
envoie à roméo salta cette photo de lui
avec le visage tuméfié ainsi qu'une
liste des 42 sévices que lui aurait fait
subir un homme prénommé manie pas ma
femme m'a dit que quelqu'un l'avait
forcé à faire certaines choses à un
animal un chat je crois qu'ils ne
voulaient pas faire roméo salta nous a
confié qu'il avait offert à luca manioc
tas de déposer une plainte contre le
prénommé manille mais que manioc taf
avait refusé pendant que luca manyoza
est à new york
le groupe facebook de ryan bourque
explose
il atteint les 5000 membres il devient
de plus en plus difficile d'éviter les
dérapages
[Musique]
cinq mille personnes
c'est l'équivalent d'une foule à
contrôler on a ciblé des gens qui
n'auraient pas dû l'être
quelques individus sont faussement
accusé par des membres du groupe
facebook d'être le tueur de chatons ils
sont victimes de harcèlement et
d'intimidation rails on doit faire des
excuses et publier des photos
rétablissant leur innocence
on n'était pas des professionnels ou que
nous on est un enquêteur qualifier on
avance et on faisait des erreurs on
apprenait nos erreurs les internautes
vont suivre plusieurs fausses pistes
jusqu'à ce qu'un internaute anonyme les
remettre sur la bonne voie sans moi
quelqu'un a soumis la photo sans visage
brouillé
cette photo reçu plusieurs jours plus
tôt avait été altéré pour cacher le
visage du suspect
la nouvelle en noir et blanc et
l'original le prochain défi est de
mettre un nom sur ce visage tourné bas
par les mots du moment où vous avez
découvert qui c'était we want it all
il nous a dit qu'il était cronenbourg il
envoyait un message facebook à un nos
membres qui disait la personne que vous
cherchez s'appelle luca manioc tas n'est
pas une blague
le courriel est anonyme
mais les membres du groupe sont
persuadés qu'il a été envoyé par luca
manioc tas lui même
même chose pour ces photos elle aurait
aussi été envoyé par mme agnetha sous un
pseudonyme peuple mais pourquoi vous
pensez qu'il vous envoyer les photos les
informations à propos de son nombre
noreen connaissons luca comme on connaît
son narcissisme l'emporter
on pense qu'il cherchait notre attention
qu'il était fâché de ne pas la voir
alors il s'est dit je vais simplement
leur dire qui je suis
[Musique]
après la pause
manute à se donne de l'importance en
s'inventant une relation avec karla
homolka luca n'éprouve pas d'émotions et
il est incapable de ressentir la
culpabilité la honte où quelques
émotions humaines
il limite les émotions des autres parce
qu'ils n'en a pas c'est un psychopathe
il vit maintenant dans les caraïbes avec
sa nouvelle épouse
karla homolka
[Musique]
ou des fois il avait l'air complètement
normal tout cas j ai senti qu il
semblait être juste dingue
il est tout essayé pour devenir célèbre
il est elle est une émission pour les
mordus de la chirurgie esthétique
il voulait être célébrant les dominants
mais personne ne s'intéressait à lui ils
voulaient que ça change et loup on
devait découvrir qui était ce garçon-là
janvier 2011
un an et demi avant la mort de line john
les membres du groupe facebook connaît
enfin l'identité de celui qui serait
l'auteur de la vidéo des chatons
asphyxiés
luca romagnoli une recherche de base sur
internet génère une multitude de pages
d'informations à son sujet il n'y avait
plus de 50 sites web une longue liste de
noms d'utilisateurs youtube
luca magnate a écrit sous de nombreux
pseudonymes
les internautes ne peuvent que déduire
que c'est lui qui se cache derrière ces
pages où fiction et réalité
s'entremêlent
première découverte luca manioc ta
s'appelait autrefois eric clinton kurt
newman il a grandi en ontario et à
changer son nom en 2006 à l'âge de 24
ans au début de la vingtaine luca magne
auteurs vit à toronto et tente de faire
carrière dans l'industrie du sexe comme
sarah doukas
il tourne quelques mauvais film
pornographique travail comme danseur nu
et prostituées tente de faire carrière
comme mannequin
sur le web les internautes découvrent
des centaines de photos de looks ammann
iota
il y a aussi des vidéos d'auto promotion
probablement mis en ligne par luca magne
auteur lui même
vivez dormait et respirer sur internet
il était tout le temps là dessus
luca manioc ta utilise son ordinateur
pour donner une image de lui qui n'a
rien à voir avec la réalité et of the
times il volait les photos des gens sur
internet free est remplacé leurs visages
par le 16 alors on le voyait au volant
d'une voiture de luxe bien dense et
jacuzzi osant sur une plage aussi au
kindle mais il était sur l'aide sociale
il était pauvre il crée ce monde
fantaisiste
il s'invente une vie sur internet il
voulait que tout le monde la voit les
internautes ont retrouvé les originaux
des photos que luca magna aurait
trafiqué pour faire croire qu'ils
possèdent une ferrari qui les mannequins
qu'il fait régulièrement la fête avec
des amis qu'il a épousé une femme russe
prénommé oksana qu'il est en voyage à
miami
tout cela ne facilite pas la tâche des
internautes qui veulent savoir dans
quelle ville ou kaman iota aurait commis
son crime et où il se cache
on devait savoir quelle autorité allait
voir où ils devaient être avec les deux
photos trouvées sur internet vont
révéler dans quelle ville les chatons
auraient été tués
les internautes ont déjà identifié que
cette photo a été prise dans la chambre
où les chatons ont été tués mais
l'analyse des données ne révèle pas dans
quelle ville elle a été prise c'est
cette deuxième photo prise avec un
téléphone cellulaire muni d'un gps qui
va trahir ma nyota l'analyse des données
révèle qu'elle a été prise au centre
eaton de toronto
quelques heures seulement après celle ci
le crime aurait donc été commis à
toronto
on connaissait son nom look ammann iota
on savait où il vivait à l'époque on
pensait qu'il était à toronto et on
avait déduit qu'il avait fait la vidéo
avec les chatons fin 2010 on pensait
avoir suffisamment d'informations pour
contacter les autorités
en février 2011 deux mois après le
meurtre des chatons john green prend
contact avec l'agent brad dewar
enquêteurs et porte parole à la société
pour la prévention de la cruauté envers
les animaux
quand on a affaire à ce genre de cas qui
est en quelque sorte un cybercrime
c'est très complexe et on n'est pas en
mesure de réagir instantanément
nous devons faire appel à d'autres
agences qui ont la capacité et la
technologie pour nous aider la spa
demande l'aide de la police de toronto
ils ont immédiatement ouvert un dossier
qui les ont transmis à l'unité de
cybercriminalité au canada tuer ou faire
souffrir inutilement un animal est un
acte criminel
la police de toronto doit trouver luca
manioc ta l'interroger et déposer des
accusations
s'il ya lieu
mais la tâche ne sera pas facile
sur internet plusieurs photos des routes
les enquêteurs et les internautes
luca manioc ta semble être partout à la
fois
il aimait se faire prendre en photo
partout n'importe où il posait je
prenais des photos lui jetait son
photographe
les internautes ont retrouvé la trace de
vénerie un retraité de toronto qui a
fréquenté luca manioc tas en 2010 avant
le meurtre des chatons c'est lui qui a
fait voyager manioc ta m'avait dit qu'il
était riche et moi je voulais voir le
métro de moscou
entre autres choses à sède alors j'ai
dit de tuer la moscou
son visage s'est illuminé d'un coup et
il a dit oui
or we caen demain il voulait vraiment
voir la place rouge
je nuis emmène aussi luca manioc tas en
europe où il se fait photographier
devant les monuments célèbres ces photos
on est des mânes iota à présenter de lui
sur internet une image de mannequins de
calibre international
[Musique]
emery est fasciné par luca manioc tu as
même s'il sent que celui-ci lui demande
s'il a dit un jour qu'il vivait dans un
roman savon alors je lui ai demandé un
accès et tu certain qu'il n'est pas
l'auteur du roman savon est-ce qu'il
était violent parfois non non je ne les
ai jamais vus être violent il était
toujours doux et calme
je pense que je n'ai jamais vu s'est
fâché si emery avait fait un peu de
recherche sur internet il aurait
découvert le côté sombre de son
compagnon de voyage dans ce texte
probablement mis en ligne par luca magne
auteur lui même en 2008
on lit qui les psychopathes luca
n'éprouve pas d'émotions et il est
incapable de ressentir la culpabilité la
honte où quelques émotions humaines
il limite les émotions des autres parce
qu'il n'en a pas c'est un psychopathe il
vit maintenant dans les caraïbes avec sa
nouvelle épouse
karla homolka
nous avons trouvé plusieurs textes
anonymes qui associe luca manioc tas et
karla homolka
man iota semble assoiffés de notoriété
en 2007 il utilise la rumeur qu'il fait
probablement lui même courir pour faire
parler de lui
il se présente au toronto sun et demande
à rencontrer un journaliste afin de nier
publiquement sa relation avec homolka
plus les internautes en apprennent sur
le gamma nyota plus ils sont inquiets
que la police ne l'ait pas encore
retrouvé on leur avait donné le nom et
le lieu
pourquoi est-ce qu'ils n'arrivaient pas
à trouver cette personne c'était très
frustrant qu'on ne pouvait rien faire de
plus il avait gagné
lorsqu'on a pu confirmer que c'était
bien son adresse il n'y habitaient déjà
plus à compter de ce jour
il s'est volatilisé luca manioc tapas
beaucoup de temps sur internet
comment se fait-il que les enquêteurs de
la police de toronto n'arrive pas à
trouver l'endroit d'où il se connecte
sur internet chaque ordinateur et
pourtant identifié par un numéro qu'on
appelle l'adresse ip
cette adresse ip permettent
habituellement de savoir où se trouve
l'ordinateur
à ce stade ils avaient appris comment
masquer son adresse ip
il existe certains programmes que vous
pouvez installer dans votre ordinateur
qui changent l'adresse ip 1 2 3 4 en 6 7
8 9 ce qui fait croire que vous êtes
dans un autre lieu
c'est ce qu'ils avaient appris à faire
en octobre 2011
après dix mois d'enquêté le groupe
décide de lâcher prise
sauf si on arrêtait de s'intéresser à
lui
et puis un mois plus tard un mois plus
tard
le cauchemar recommence deux nouvelles
vidéos font surface sur internet
la première est mise en ligne le 28
novembre 2011
on y voit un chaton se faire dévorer par
un énorme python dans la deuxième
un chat est attaché sur un bâton est
noyée dans un bain je crois que c'était
sa façon de nous dire vous ne
m'attaquerai jamais je fais ce que je
veux je peux faire d'autres vidéos les
mettre en ligne et jamais vous ne me
retrait serait après la pause les
indices s'accumulent et inquiète de plus
en plus qu'on ne sait pas s'il va
s'arrêter là ou s'il est capable de
passer au niveau supérieur
des gens se font la main sur les animaux
et quand ça ne suffit plus à nourrir
leur maladie il passe à une autre
victime qu'il juge sans défense
[Musique]
nous sommes en décembre 2011
quelques semaines après la découverte
des nouveaux vidéos de chatons
assassiner les internautes trouvent
cette photo de luca manioc tas à londres
pourquoi publier une photo de lui devant
le palais de buckingham
dans quel but pourquoi voudrait-il
soudainement que l'on sache où ils se
trouvent les internautes croient que
luca magna veut leur faire diriger leurs
recherches dans la mauvaise direction
istres ils essaient de brouiller les
pistes il ne faut pas aller là où il
veut nous mener
il n'est pas en grande bretagne c'est
impossible
erreur luca manioc tas est vraiment à
londres le 8 décembre il débarque dans
les bureaux d'un quotidien de la
capitale qui vient de publier un article
sur les vidéos de chatons le coma nyota
s'est présenté dans les bureaux du sol
en disant je suis luca manioc temps
pourquoi me harceler vous et on a dit on
nous harcèle pas on ne l'avait pas
appelé on n'avait pas essayé de le
trouver
c'était vraiment bizarre qui se présente
comme luca manioc tas se plaint d'être
faussement accusé d'avoir tué les
chatons à tréguer le journaliste alex
ouest l'accompagnent à l'hôtel où il
loge pour faire une entrevue il me
perturbait il ne faisait pas il me
donnait la chair de poule
il ya quelque chose qui n'allait pas il
n'avait pas d'émotions le journaliste
décide de ne rien publier deux jours
plus tard il reçoit un courriel signé du
nom de john kirby ride un garçon de 12
ans assassiné en 1963 par un couple de
tueurs en série célèbre en angleterre
alex ouest est convaincu que le courriel
a été écrit par luca manioc tu as le
plus terrifiant c'est qu'il disait que
la prochaine fois ce ne serait pas des
voici ce que disait le courriel
une fois que tu as tué goûté au sang
c'est impossible d'arrêter l'envi est
juste trop forte
la prochaine fois que vous entendrez
parler de moi ce sera dans un film que
je suis en train de produire et qui
montrera des humains pas juste des
chatons alex ouest prend immédiatement
contact avec la police de londres
la police découvre que le courriel n'a
pas été envoyé de londres louga manioc
tas serait déjà sortis du pays
quelques jours plus tard une question
troublante apparaît sur un forum de
discussion
elle est signé d'un pseudonyme que les
internautes associent à lukla man iota
quel est le meilleur type de sédatifs je
pense que la morphine liquide est
extrêmement rapide
ça prend un peu de temps pour agir toute
l'information recueillie sur le cam
anota et transmise à l'ats jean brad
dewar de la spa qui la fait suivre à la
police de toronto
cette personne veut un public
il est fier de ce qu'il fait ils se
donnent en spectacle et c'est d'autant
plus inquiétant parce qu'on ne sait pas
s'il va s'arrêter là ou s'il est capable
de passer au niveau supérieur
ring se pose la même question
des études ont démontré que plusieurs
tueurs en série ont commencé leur
carrière de criminel en torturant des
animaux votre d'esprit pour les gens se
font la main sur les animaux et quand ça
ne suffit plus à nourrir leur maladie ou
qu'il se sent suffisamment confiant il
passe à une autre victime qu'il juge
sans défense généralement un enfant une
femme ou une personne âgée fin décembre
un individu qui semble être luca manioc
ta s'adresse directement aux internautes
sur facebook
il utilise un de ces pseudonymes
il veut nous parler c'était juste avant
noël il est probablement seul il n'a
personne à qui parler
baudimont venez john green profite de
l'occasion pour tendre une perche à
celui qu'il croit être luca maillot tu
as on voulait qu'ils sachent qu'on ne
représentait pas une menace qu'on ne lui
voulait aucun mal on voulait tout
simplement les dés qu'on avait trouvé
toutes ces informations à son sujet et
qu'il avait besoin d aide
rien ne l'empêchait de se faire soigner
c'était à lui d'agir
quelques jours après cet échange ça n'a
reçu plusieurs photos par courriel et
sur facebook qui selon nous ont été
envoyées par le cas des images de
flacons de médicaments rempli sur
lesquelles était inscrit le nom de luca
les cinq médicaments qui figure sur les
photos ont été prescrits en 2007 par un
psychiatre
les soupçons des internautes se confirme
lucas manioc ta souffrirait d'un
problème de santé mentale
[Musique]
l'information est immédiatement
transmise à la police de toronto
quelques semaines plus tard john green
reçoit ce courriel du détective qui
chargé du dossier il n'y a personne qui
veut trouver ce gala plus que moi je
veux l'emmener en cours ne serait ce que
pour qu'ils aient des soins
psychiatriques
[Musique]
nous avons découvert que les problèmes
de santé mentale de luca manioc tas
était présent dès 2005
en juin 2005 il a été reconnu coupable
de fraude en ontario au moment de rendre
son jugement la juge a accepté de
laisser purger sa peine dans la
communauté aux conditions suivantes
suivre un traitement pour problèmes de
santé mentale et prendre tous les
médicaments prescrits en s'adressant
tamagno ta directement elle ajoute si
vous ne prenez pas vos médicaments votre
vie va déraper
[Musique]
février 2012 les internautes ne le
savent pas encore mais luca manioc tas
n'est plus à toronto
il retrouve sa trace en regardant cette
vidéo il y avait de nouvelles photos de
luca que je n'avais jamais vu il était
assis sur des marches et portait un
survêtement violée en staps en utilisant
le logiciel google maps les internautes
découvrent que la photo a été prise ici
sur le campus de l'université mcgill
luca manioc tas serait à montréal
en fait il y est depuis plusieurs mois
comme en témoigne cette série de photos
prises par un photographe professionnel
le 1er mai 2011 dans le quartier
pointe-saint-charles près de cet
immeuble ou man iota occupe un petit
appartement
un des membres de notre groupe est allé
voir la police de montréal pour leur
parler
l'agent a répondu qu'il n'y avait aucun
mandat d'arrêt contre lui et qu'a priori
ils n'avaient commis aucun crime
ils ne pouvaient donc rien faire c est
chaud ce n'est pas un crime oui mais
malheureusement la police ne prend pas
ça au sérieux
à peu près au même moment le 16 mars
un texte sordide apparaît sur internet
il présente luca manioc tas comme un
tueur en série nécrophile et cannibales
c'était deux mois à peine avant la mort
de ligne jaune tous les signes était
tout indiqué qu'il allait tuer quelqu'un
je dire il l'est vraiment tuer quelqu'un
après la pause les internautes loin
d'être surpris du meurtre aïcha je n'en
revenais pas et en même temps je m'y
attendais sur facebook les gens disaient
on ne vous l'avait dit oui oui oui
[Musique]
deux colis contenant des restes humains
ont été retrouvés
le premier contenait un pied il a été
livré au bureau du parti conservateur du
canada le 29 mai 2012 quand les
policiers retrouvent le cadavre de
l'étudiant line john lucas manioc tas
est déjà loin c'est sans doute ce soir
l'un des hommes les plus recherchés de
la planète l'uqar au covan iota
soupçonné d'avoir commis ce crime
horrible à montréal a probablement déjà
quitté line john a été assassiné dans
l'appartement qu'occupait luca man iota
à montréal
arusha je n'en revenais pas mais en même
temps je m'y attendais sur facebook les
gens disaient vous l'avez dit j'étais
enragé
on avait passé près de deux ans à
essayer que sept personnes obtiennent
des soins dans une institution
quelconque
et voilà qu il tuer quelqu'un
[Musique]
le lendemain du crime luca manioc ta
s'enfuit en europe
[Musique]
le surlendemain une vidéo du meurtre de
line john est mise en ligne de même que
j'ai vu d'image apparaître je me suis
dit c'est encore le cas j'ai tout de
suite envoyé un courriel aux détectives
à toronto et je lui ai dit il faut que
vous regardiez cette vidéo on croit que
c'est encore luca
les corps policiers du monde entier se
mobilise pour retrouver luca manioc tas
il a malheureusement fallu attendre
qu'une vie humaine soit sacrifié pour
que les gens commencent à prendre cette
histoire au sérieux
les internautes sont amers ils auraient
souhaité que les choses bougent à 20
même si les seules preuves disponibles
étaient virtuels le fait est que pour
eux aux oreilles à nadal toute notre
information tout notre preuves provenant
d'internet pour eux ce n'était pas
vraiment crédible pour y est
les policiers sont ils bien formés et
outillés pour enquêter sur cette
nouvelle forme de criminalité qui se
déploie dans le cyberespace
l'internet est un nouvel univers pour
les forces de l'ordre ce n'est pas tout
le monde qui comprend comment fonctionne
l'internet et ce qu'il s'y passe il faut
presque faire leur éducation
il est difficile de jeter la pierre aux
policiers puisque nous ne savons pas ce
qu'ils ont fait pour retrouver le clama
nyota la police de toronto a refusé de
répondre à nos questions en raison du
processus judiciaire qui est en cours
ce que nous avons découvert par contre
c'est que deux mois avant la mort de
line john la police de toronto et la spc
a de l'ontario était très près du but
quand ils ont réussi à localiser une
adresse à montréal
ils se sont rendus sur place mais ils
avaient déjà quitté les lieux
il avait retrouvé l'adresse de luca
magne et à pointe saint charles
mais trop tard man iota venait tout
juste de déménager dans l'immeuble où
line john a été assassiné
[Musique]
malgré la triste fin de l'histoire
les internautes croient qu'ils ont fait
avancer les choses
je pense qu'on a mis en évidence le lien
qui existe entre la cruauté envers les
animaux et l'escaladent vers les crimes
plus odieux avant cette affaire j'avais
seulement lu des études qui parlait des
gens qui tuer des animaux pour ensuite
tuer des humains mais je peux dire
aujourd'hui que j'en ai été témoin si à
l'avenir on croise de nouveau quelqu'un
dans le genre on n'attendra pas on
passera tout de suite à l'action
ironiquement celui qui a vécu par
internet a perdu sa liberté à cause
d'internet
le 4 juin 2012 après une semaine de
cavale
luca manioc tas a été arrêté dans un
cybercafé de berlin en allemagne
on s'est fait arrêté alors qu'il
regardait des photos de lui il n'a pas
pu résister il est à lire ce que les
gens disaient de lui pendant qu'il était
en fuite il n'a pas pu résister lucas
manioc tas a été rapatrié au canada deux
semaines après son arrestation il a
plaidé non coupable à toutes les
accusations qui pèsent contre lui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
lucas manioc tas sera de retour devant
les tribunaux pour son enquête
préliminaire
en mars prochain les internautes ont
depuis fondé un groupe permanent de
cyber enquête pour traquer d'autres
pensionnaires d'animaux vous pouvez les
suivre sur leur site internet du animals
péta project
[Musique]
tous
si vous voulez nous contacter et
consultez notre site internet à
l'adresse suivante vous pouvez faire vos
commentaires et vos suggestions et
revoir le reportage pour connaître notre
démarche journalistique
je vous invite à consulter mon blogue
veuillez prendre note qu'en qu'être une
diffusée le samedi à 13h sur la première
chaîne de radio-canada et le dimanche à
18 heures sur le réseau de l'information
merci d'avoir été là bonsoir à la
semaine prochaine
[Musique]